it felt like thing of the Academy Awards  or something every person had been in  one or all of my fiber films it was like  a sea of people who have grown up  watching in one place hanging out  there's a ton of fanboy and fan Girling  going on in that room with each other  that was crazy it's a little bit like  being drafted to a sports team that has  a legacy of championship banners as a  dream come true  looking around at long like what did I  do to deserve this  hey I literally am in dead center in the  front row and I'm looking around and  going any one of these people could be  dead center I mean you just everywhere  you looked was another superhero movie  star I think everyone was aware this was  coming to a close we'd all been on this  remarkable journey together thank you  all for coming thank you for trusting us  thank you for joining this it's been ten  years in the Marvel Cinematic Universe  it was huge excitement and buzz to that  time  you